life has been amazing crazy all the
things i'm normally in bed right now
this is way past my bedtime but this is
well worth it
uh everything's going good my world has
just flipped upside down with my
sweet little girl and um i've announced
that i'm going to be going on tour this
year with thomas rhett so i'm excited
for that and excited to get back out on
the road so
life is good it's good carrie underwood
has been somebody who's been
extremely nice to me um even when i was
pregnant
you know she's just she's just awesome
she just
had said if you ever needed any advice
or whatnot
just let me know and of course i took
her up on that because i need all the
advice i can
i can i can have with babies um so
she's been absolutely amazing with that
and
uh any any anybody else that hears this
i would love some more advice and some
help on anything mommy related so
but thank you to carrie for that okay
how have i celebrated my win
uh i went back and changed a dirty
diaper that's what i did
last april i hope went number one yes
okay so
so so two number ones um
covid um pregnant baby
um oh my gosh too many things
uh debut album
um